Recall that the effect of running any function with the keyword new is that
that functions runs as if it had a bit of extra code in it.
Particularly, it's going to set the keyword this to equal some
brand newly created object.
And just because we ran the Van function with the keyword new and
created another different object, does not mean that the other function is
going to run with that same object as it's context.
These are two different object.create statments that are being inserted into two
different functions as a result of two different appearances of the keyword new.
In the diagram this would mean that any time you run the Van function with or
without the key word new, it would have the effect of building a brand new
object, that delegates to the constructor of the car class.
If your running the Van function with the key word new to begin with,
then you've already got a brand new object and you don't need a second one.
Sometimes people try to solve this by assigning the result of the new
Car invocation, this object that gets created during the Car constructor,
assigning to the local keyword this.
But only is it disallowed to assign to the keyword this at all in your own code,
even thought the interpreter is allowed to do such things,
it doesn't solve the fact that you wind up having two different object,
one of which you would be apparently throwing away.
So this solution just doesn't work.
Simple enough.
What if we were to call the Car function without the keyword new?
Perhaps that would have the effect of simply running the Car function in
the context that we wanted.
Unfortunately, this doesn't work either.
In this situation, what would you expect the keyword this from within
the Car function to be referring to as a result of being evoked on this line?